The general experience.
So,
um,
yeah,
so mma,
who named it mixed martial arts,
you know what that's a look at.
That's a whole story.
And you're going to hear it was you.
Well,
I give credit to Jeff Blatnick as far as
looking at.
Oh,
he didn't come up with the term who did?
But the truth,
you know,
and this is the first thing I can tell
you,
I wrote,
I wrote a,
uh,
I had to do what's called a work permit
for lapd because I worked for lapd back
in 1993 93 in [inaudible] 94.
And it was because I was going to
referee the second UFC which was March
11th of 1994.
And for me to actually work,
the department has to allow me to,
I have to ask for permission and then
they have to grant that permission.
Was there a concern that it was too
outrageous?
That was part of the whole thing is I
didn't want to say,
oh,
I got two guys going into a cage.
They're going to beat the shit out of
each other.
Right.
So the first thing I put was martial
arts referee.
Hm,
okay.
And then they said,
well,
what kind of martial arts?
So I wrote mixed martial arts referee,
now I can tell you that that was in 90,
right at the end of [inaudible] 93.
And the term I didn't get it from
anywhere other than I'm sitting there
trying to think it.
But I do know that there was a
columnist,
a sports writer from the La Times that
wrote about the very first UFC and in
his article wrote mixed martial arts.
Ah,
so maybe it was him.
So I.
well you got John Perretti saying that
he's,
you know,
he did it back in 1983 and it's like,
okay,
well if no one's saying it,
it doesn't mean shit.
Right.
Okay.
So the truth of the matter is,
so already might have said it in 83,
he might have said it,
but it didn't mean anything because the
fact of the matter is,
and it doesn't matter what I wrote,
what matters is when you know,
when you joined,
when you joined the UFC,
it was still considered no holds barred
NHB yeah.
And it was what we called it and it was
something that was,
and this is probably part of my problem
with Campbell Mclaren is back before UFC
two,
you know,
good.
They had them on Good Morning America
with Jim Brown and you go back to that
and he came up with the line that you
could win by knockout,
tap out or death.
Okay.
And for years after that I was in court
having that thrown in my face by the
fricken attorney trying to put us down
saying,
isn't this what you're companies?
No,
that's not what my son says.
That's what an idiot said.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so he still to this day things,
he was magnificent with that.
Maybe it was kind of demonic ceremony.
Maybe it wouldn't be a problem at all.
Here's the deal.
It's all one thing getting fucked up.
Shamonic,
whatever.
If you in drugs and you fucked up,
you fucked up.
Doesn't matter if it's shamonic or not.
If you.
If you get high and that tweaks,
that little thing in my brain that goes
on here.
I go.
Remember in your brain,
I got high for 30 years.
I'm from the sixties with the best of
them.
I got high and it took them down.
Some of them,
most of them.
You came through it remarkably unscathed
if you think about it.
Yeah.
Thank you God.
It's pretty amazing.
Think about that one.
Yeah.
Think about that.
We could talk for two hours.
About Times I did shit and almost died.
So.
Sure.
You know,
and then I could also tell you
how many times I took shit and wrote
things like,
you know,
I'm listening to this guitar lick that
chose plan.
He did an interview here with you,
but he didn't tell you how it his
fucking sleep.
He would play these riffs and I come
down the hallway because,
you know,
as I see it,
of course not as ace it,
but as I see it,
we were up in New England and he was
playing at a place and I mowed the lawn,
my,
my parents place and I quit my last band
and I was fucking a little who saw her.
I was crying.
I was no more bands.
The dream was over.
He drives up in an mg we go and he's
playing that night.
I swear to God this happened and so we
decided to move down to Boston,
but all in an apartment because I
thought I knew why those bands didn't
make it,
but I knew in my heart that if I had a
broan band,
like I'm making a keith.
Like the kinks.
Yeah.
David,
Dave,
and you know ray,
any of those bands they had,
they had,
you know,
have.
It was two guys that were really tight.
They feed off each other.
The Fed off each other.
Exactly.
So we moved down there.
I got really tight with Joe.
I hear him.
He gets,
we get so swept.
We were so stoned on blue boone's farm.
I mean fucking.
I said,
what'd you say?
What'd you say?
Anyway,
but he would play these licks.
It was so fucking for every song you've
ever heard.
Sweet emotion.
Every one of those legs walk this way.
There's 20 that got lost in the ether,
right?
Twenty that got lost in the ether.
So I went out and bought a little thing
on the tape recorder back then.
Remember this was 71.
You know,
a lot of shit wasn't no phones,
no cell phones.
So I would record that shit.
So anyway,
what we're going with this,
that's,
that's what,
that's where these songs came from and
stuff would come out of my head while I
was like sweet
white,
Ypo.
Fuck.
Get me paper,
paper and pen.
I write that shit down suddenly.
Whoops.
On the radio.
See?
So I used that place.
You get you go to,
when you eat edibles,
do you ever write some of your routines
when you know for sure?
Well and also check this out.
The best part of it is when I got sober,
I started writing even better shit.
I go in a room with four guys and say,
we're going into right ahead.
We're going to say in this fucking room
until we do or until we can't stay in
each of the smell
and we would leave in seven hours with a
fucking song and a good one and one that
would live way past all of us.
Check that shooter,
but that's a lot of damage out.
What can be done is the ideas can die.
The ideas of of fascism,
the ideas of racism,
the,
those,
those things we can kill,
but are those ideas,
are those ideas being fostered in these,
in these communities?
Yes.
Yeah.
They're being cultivated.
Yeah,
because you experienced it.
Yeah.
I mean if I'm a white guy,
white guy walking down the street,
I am.
I am a higher degree than the locals.
You know,
like I can.
I can go and shop in some places that
they can't.
I can go in and sit down and have a meal
in some places that they can't.
I can and being greeted on the street.
Good Morgan,
you know,
I'm not,
not the brown dude next to me.
He's not.
And His kid definitely can't date the
blue eyed blonde girl at the high
school.
That's not allowed.
So they'll basically created these
little colonies.
Yeah.
Yahtzee colonies in South America.
Did you Google Google Colonia dignity
data?
Yeah.
Did you?
You will have nightmares.
Do not freak it out right now.
It's diverse.
It's crazy how many people got away with
it that Joseph Mengele died on a beach.
That's Lillian wife.
I mean that,
that,
that would hurt me because he's a guy
like me just on the ops because he,
I mean,
he's a special operations guy.
He was an ss.
Um,
he,
he was,
he was a physical specimen,
especially for the time,
you know,
like we didn't,
we didn't understand.
I mean,
he was,
he was very early on into the,
one of the first real Nazis,
like,
this isn't okay.
All of Germany's going this way.
The chancellor is Adolf Hitler.
This is where we're going.
I kind of just have to go along and you
see some of that in the third year,
like 43,
44 now it's okay.
We might be losing this war now.
It's not so in vogue,
but when you got guys like 1939 that are
talking to eugenics and um,
you know,
higher calling for breeding and
segregation.
Um,
early on you're like,
Eh,
I don't like that guy.
Kona beat him to death with my hands,
but he's massive.
So it'd be a pretty good fight.
It was a,
there we go form Nazi cult.
Trying to.
What does it say?
Jimmy was the full,
uh,
full Nazi Colt.
What is the uh,
so that,
that,
that's just a marketing thing because
it's still the same place.
Reformed Nazi,
cult trying to open it's colony to.
And is this,
that's in Chile?
Yeah.
I spent a lot of time.
They're right there.
How they made a movie about it.
So that's current day right there.
Jesus Christ.
That later hose in range is freaking
gorgeous though.
It's,
I mean it is Shangri la.
Yeah,
German flag flying.
Wow.
They've tried to hide the Nazi things
they've had.
I've met some people that I'm like,
I talked to him.
I go,
oh,
I'm like a monkey
dude.
I talked to your Buddy Eddie Bravo,
and that guy is a real.
He's out there.
He's like a.
he's like a deaf deaf Jack Russell
almost,
you know,
a deaf Jack Russell,
because once he gets going,
you can't.
Oh,
Jack Russell terrier?
Yeah.
You ever been around with the dog?
You open the car and then next thing you
know they're like,
oh yeah,
they're like sick.
Yeah,
but how's he depth?
Because you can't get them back.
Like once he goes,
you can't say you can't get them back in
the car.
Like you're sitting there honking the
horn.
You can't that guys out there,
you know my home.
You know what I'm talking about.
Two totally talking about,
but I've never heard anybody make a
description like that.
Jack Russell terrier.
That is hilarious.
Extravagant dude.
That means extravagant.
He's motivated.
He loves conspiracies more than anybody
I've ever met in my life.
And he thinks everything is a
conspiracy.
Yeah.
No,
no,
he definitely.
Yeah,
but then he gets into it like,
I dunno,
it was fascinating to me how he went
from this like one genre of life to the
next and created a business in each one
and kept moving forward.
A business.
Yeah.
He got like,
he was a,
he liked music.
He started a band,
you know,
he liked karate.
He started doing,
um,
you know,
organized karate.
He liked,
uh,
you know,
what else did he pee?
A couple of other businesses.
I think you got a new couple of other
things.
I don't know what the other two.
He lost the,
uh,
chapter 70.
But he'll hit you with too much
information.
Man.
It was crazy.
A lot of people to Google.
I was like,
I want to climb through a black hole
right now into a case he did shit.
Like,
wait a minute,
is this guy legit?
Dude?
The other night 2:00 AM,
he sends me a couple of links.
You got to shut your phone off friends
with Eddie.